and finally new rule Republicans have to
stop being surprised when their instant
heroes turn out to be embarrassments
they're so anxious to buddy up to the
Forgotten good people that when a Kim
Davis or a Joe the plumber or a cliven
Bundy come along they rush to say now
here's a real American when they should
be saying what's up with this [ __ ]
and if these better than the rest of us
real Americans really do exist how come
every time you find when they turn out
to be a creep either you're a terrible
judge of character or else there's
nobody home with the good people house
now a few weeks ago America met Kim
Davis the Kentucky Court Clerk who was
sent to jail for her principal belief
that marriage is a sacred union between
one woman and one scarecrow Kim refused
to perform her job marrying gay people
on account of her Jesus freedoms an
overnight became a martyr a Joan of Arc
for the deep-fried Twinkie crowd here
she is getting her official Religious
Freedom Award still wrapped in plastic
so it'll match her furniture but what
Kim Davis turned out to be everything
conservatives hate she gave birth to two
children out of wedlock and she's been
married four times according to her the
answer to what would Jesus do is
everybody
Oh last year's Kim Davis was a guy
perfectly named cliven Bundy if you
forgot he's the not so jolly rancher who
wanted to graze his cattle on public
lands without paying the fees like
everybody else sorry mr. Bundy if you're
getting your grass from the government
for free then I should get my grass room
and predictably cliven went off-script
at a rally and said quote I want to tell
you one more thing about the negro and
that sentence never ends well as it
didn't this time when he went on they
abort their children and put their young
men in jail because they never learned
to pick up
and that was the end of open mic night
at the OK Corral but not the end of
racist mascots before because before
cliven we had George Zimmerman the
freelance defender of cul-de-sacs hope
conservatives insisted was neither
racist nor angry but since his trial
he's had more contact with the police
than Dunkin Donuts and I would be remiss
in this rundown of Republican none of
the Month Club members if I didn't
mention Joe the Plumber who during the
2008 election became famous as the guy
who didn't want to pay too high taxes on
his small business which it turned out
he didn't have because it would hold
back his career as a plumber which it
turned out he wasn't either and his name
wasn't Joe I'm not kidding guys it's
called Google but the Republican mascot
who for my money takes the prize is Josh
Duggar one of the fames one of the fame
19 and Counting Duggar kids beloved by
conservatives for their homespun values
their modest clothing and their mother's
womb nicknamed old faithful
Josh traded on his family's image to
work as a lobbyist for the
ultra-conservative
Family Research Council and all the
Republican presidential candidates
wanted a picture with him until it
turned out he had to Ashley Madison
accounts had paid for rough sex with
porn stars
and had molested his sisters although to
be fair I guess molesting your sisters
could be considered family research
you